so we haven't checked in for a little
bit about what's going on with
coronavirus so i want to spend a little
time today
it's been a weekend we have another
several days of data we now have more
averages and trends to look at
and i want to go a little deeper than
just cases and deaths but let's start
there
as of this morning the united states had
more than 5.2
million confirmed coronavirus cases
and just shy of 166 000 deaths
now remember that in terms of deaths
donald trump said
through april and may first he said 15
cases will soon be zero that didn't work
out
in april may donald trump said well we
could end up with 50 or 60 000 deaths
then it became clear it's gonna be more
trump moved the goal post to 70 80
000. 90 100 000. now it's about keeping
it under 200 000. now
the official death toll at 166 later in
the show
i'm going to talk to you about the
actual death toll now
really is probably more like 225 because
of the
uncounted coronavirus deaths let me not
get ahead of myself we'll get to that a
little bit later but okay that we're
officially at 166
000. now in terms of cases per capita
the states now at the top of the list
are louisiana arizona
florida new york mississippi new jersey
alabama georgia
south carolina rhode island and nevada
and what you're seeing is that what
early
in terms of per capita cases were
exclusively these blue state hot spots
as a result of
which states have the direct flights to
these source
contagion regions there's been a shift
to red states not just
in the total number of cases but in
cases per capita because now it's about
policy early it was about
who had the bad luck or timing is what i
i guess i would call it
uh to before we really knew about the
virus
have a lot of direct flights to china
and the source countries in europe like
italy and it was
you know boston new york new jersey area
chicago illinois
the california airports rhode island by
virtue of being very close to boston
also was hit very hard
now it's about who's testing
who has guidelines where are people
wearing masks etc
so now it's about policy cases
of course depend on tests and how much
testing you were doing
and as we know as i told you last week
florida and california as examples
were under reporting cases for different
reasons florida because of the hurricane
california
for still some unknown reason so when
you look at one of these examples let's
look at for example
florida because of the decreased testing
in florida
florida cases started declining in late
july
except we know why they aren't testing
as much because of the hurricane
but if you look instead of it cases at
hospitalizations during the last week
florida had a record for single week
new hospitalizations for coronavirus
just over 3 300 that's more than
500 new hospitalizations per day
including 621 hospitalizations
in florida last wednesday that's not
what you want to see and it's another
signal of how
you can affect cases by not testing by
changing reporting
hospitalizations are a really important
indicator now meanwhile
for political reasons donald trump is
talking about
every country now is seeing a resurgence
and the reason trump is doing this is if
he can point to
spain is having a wave too italy's
having a wave too
i guess he thinks it makes the united
states response look less
bad but there's a few really important
things to think about as we look at some
european countries
see numbers start to climb again first
of all we've been expecting a second
wave
since march this was what doctors
thought would happen
decrease in the summer back up as we
approach fall
in the u.s we never even had the gap
because when we got down to 20 000 cases
per day
most states started reopening which is
crazy
now to the other piece yes if you look
at
some european countries now like spain
they are seeing a resurgence in cases
but they're immediately putting the
guidelines back in place
and people are mostly following them so
when the president points to
we're doing fine because there are
second waves in europe well first
reaction is
we knew and expected all along that
there would be a second wave
in the u.s we've been so acutely
terrible that we didn't even get a break
from wave one to wave two and we're now
approaching the fall ourselves
secondly the other countries see the
rise
and they put the guidelines back in
place paris is now ramping back
up masking rules and putting measures
back in place trump points to spain and
france to justify
not having taken it seriously but the
problem with his logic is
they did take it seriously and
immediately are starting to right away
it's completely incoherent
but it's where we are today and all we
can do is deal with it
real quick uh august 23rd
is the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show this is a really big deal
we're on track for a million youtube
subscribers this year
our podcast has grown 40 percent in the
last three months
and we're hitting 15 years so on the
23rd
we will have a huge very special
membership special which you can be
notified of by grabbing a
free newsletter subscription at
davidpakman.com
this is very exciting we're doing
something crazy that i may even regret
some governors would probably call the
membership special we're planning
illegal and immoral i would even say but
we're going to persevere and do it so
get on our newsletter at davidpakman.com
august 23rd a big big day
in david pakman show history